[Applauso]
imbarazzante
questo silenzio vero si ha quasi la
tentazione di volerlo interrompere come
se qualcosa non andasse
pensate che questo è stato solamente un
minuto di silenzio un minuto di oltre
100.000 minuti passati così per
l'esattezza 103 mila 680 minuti a quanto
equivalgono equivalgono a 72 giorni
quelli necessari per andare
partendo da bobbio nella val trebbia
fino a santiago de compostela a piedi
con voto di silenzio il primo passo
silenziosa e stato proprio lì sul ponte
gobbo di bobbio un luogo a me caro per
ricordi d'infanzia e sappiamo bene come
è importante la destinazione ma
altrettanto importante anche la partenza
perché certi luoghi danno in qualche
modo protezione da bobbio mi sono
diretto verso gli appennini quelle
montagne che conosco bene dormendo in
tenda o potuto godere di quella natura
che troppe volte davo per scontata
proprio perché dietro casa
sono sceso giù in liguria e o
costeggiato tutta la riviera di ponente
ligure per arrivare fino al confine con
la francia
lì sono entrato nella mary meravigliosa
costa azzurra in provenza territori
straordinari persone gentili sulla mia
via paesi città molto importanti come
hard come aix en provence oppure posti
come il monte san vito ha reso famoso
dal maestro cézanne per 25 giorni
il clima è stato dalla mia parte sempre
avuto il sole in faccia mai una nuvola
nonostante fossi partito a settembre
quindi in autunno
poi però le cose sono precipitate una
volta entrato in occitania lì a pochi
chilometri da carcassonne per pochissimo
evitato l'esondazione del fiume od un
fiume un'esondazione che ha causato ben
tredici morti ed è stato il primo
momento sul cammino
cui ho realizzato in qualche modo di
essere protetto perché c'è mancato
davvero poco che non ci lasciasse le
tende solo grazie a una concatenazione
di eventi fortuiti e invece invece
qualche giorno dopo li sui pirenei
ho compiuto il giro di boa in mille
chilometri per arrivare poi in un altro
luogo molto significativo lourdes una
città ovviamente importante da un punto
di vista religioso ma non solo l'area
mistica di quel luogo è un luogo che
quando mi chiedono ma dove iniziare il
cammino
io consiglierei proprio da questo
santuario invece solitamente il cammino
quello che viene chiamato il cammino
francese il più famoso di tutti inizia
qualche giorno più in là di cammino
ovvero assange ampie debord un piccolo
villaggio sui pirenei dove la porta di
san giacomo
inizia per l'appunto il cammino francese
nome ironico perché tra l'altro proprio
lì è la prima tappa ti porta a
roncisvalle a valicare i pirenei entrano
in spagna quindi francese c'è solamente
una giornata la salita più difficile tra
l'altro e per non farmi mancare niente
me la sono fatta sotto un'abbondante
nevicata poco male perché il giorno dopo
questo sole mi ha salutato ma non solo
mi ha salutato anche il territorio di
navarra un luogo meraviglioso per colore
in autunno giallo l'ocra l'arancione i
suoi profumi i territori della rocca con
i suoi vitigni e poi le infinite distese
degli altipiani delle mese tas 200 km
dove non si percepisce la fine arrivando
alla città di leon un ginocchio
malandato la febbre un giorno ho avuto
anche la diarrea la dissenteria
però nonostante questo sono riuscito a
fare la salita alla croce di ferro la
salita o se brero quella che porta a
questo cartello l'entrata in galizia gli
ultimi 150 chilometri prima di arrivare
a santiago il momento in cui si
comprende che se la si sta facendo che
santiago è lì pronto ad essere raggiunto
2000 189 km totali per ottenere la
compostela quell'attestato che appunto
dice che hai fatto un pellegrinaggio una
conchiglia che si raccoglie finistère
dovesse raggiungere l'oceano atlantico
appunto dopo la città con la tomba
dell'apostolo san giacomo
quante persone l'anno percorso questo
cammino tantissime centinaia di migliaia
di pellegrini nella storia e quindi cosa
ci faccio qui io a raccontarlo beh io
credo innanzitutto che la grandezza di
un'impresa non si misura col numero di
persone che l'hanno tentata ma con
quello che ti porta dentro e vi assicuro
non è stato semplice
il clima innanzitutto perché è l'autunno
le condizioni metereologiche la natura
il le vesciche ai piedi i dolori rete
sono stati dei momenti soprattutto tra
italia e francia dove dovevo inventarmi
tutti i giorni un itinerario diverso per
sfuggire appunto alle intemperie e in un
bosco di querce questo che vedete lì ho
conosciuto davvero il dolore lì ho
conosciuto davvero la voglia di mollare
volevo abbandonare tutto perché non
comprendevo come il dolore fosse
propedeutico per riuscire a crescere
nell'auto convincimento nella stima
nella tenacia dolore cerchiamo di solito
di rifiutarlo
ma invece dovremmo farcela ogni tanto
amico farci due chiacchiere riconoscerlo
non fosse altro per evitarlo
in quel bosco di querce volevo urlare ma
urlare avrebbe significato anche fallire
nel mio intento principale ovvero il
voto di silenzio
ma cosa vuol dire non comunicare non
comunicare vuol dire che non puoi
salutare non puoi dire grazie
come faccio andare in bagno ordinare un
caffè un panino oppure pensate solo come
facevo a ottenere ospitalità il citofono
finché un videocitofono dai la necessità
aguzza l'ingegno muovevo il labiale
facevo finta che l'audio non funzionasse
ma quando non citofono classico dream
che facevi davo dei colpi di tosse e poi
l'interlocutore arrivava alla porta così
come tanti altri interlocutori proprio
sul cammino è dimostrato
il mio bigliettino tradotto in cinque
lingue perché almeno un cammino
internazionale sono un pellegrino sul
cammino per santiago de compostela
ho scelto di percorrere lo facendo voto
di silenzio pertanto to parlami ma io
potrò comunicare con te solo scrivendo è
un biglietto che dava regalava sorrisi
ma a volte anche diffidenza medico ma
perché ho voluto percorrere così tanti
chilometri tutta questa fatica in
autunno in più aggiungendo un voto di
silenzio in un cammino che ha
condivisione che è conosciuto proprio
per questo determinerà un messaggio e mi
sono accorto che è tendenzialmente ci
parliamo gli uni sopra gli altri
abbiamo smesso di ascoltare e abbiamo
smesso soprattutto di ascoltarci
faccio il travel blogger lavoro sui
social devo comunicare anche certi
messaggi allora il mio silenzio
comunicava la voglia di mettermi
all'ascolto sul cammino mentre invece
comunicavo anche alle persone a casa la
voglia di mettersi ad ascoltare le altre
persone in un mondo dove chi parla più
forte degli altri riesce a farsi
sentieri io ho cercato di fare ancora
più rumore possibile con il silenzio
cos'è il cammino cos'è questo silenzio
questo senso innanzitutto ha stravolto
determinate regole
nella conversazione con l'interlocutore
perché all'inizio si presta più
attenzione ai gesti all'intonazione a
tutti quelli che sono i dettagli la
comunicazione si fa molto ma molto più
attenta non solo
l'interlocutore inizia a fidarsi perché
capisce che come di piccoli segreti che
possono essere detti senza essere
giudicati e infine un'altra tipologia è
l'attesa perché quando io dovevo
rispondere
l'altra persona stava attendendo la mia
risposta è la stessa si faceva più
paziente più attenta si poteva parlare
di qualunque cosa quindi il cammino cosa
porta ma innanzitutto mi ha fatto molto
bene mi ha rigenerato
ha riportato in asse con quelli che sono
le proprietà della vita problemi che a
volte noi riteniamo troppo grandi
insormontabili nel cammino assumono una
dimensione totalmente diversa perché ti
svegli al mattino
devi raggiungere una determinata
destinazione percorre determinati km
devi trovare un pasto caldo è un tetto
sotto cui dormire e dove sono allora
tutti i problemi che nella vita
quotidiana ci sembrano così grandi e
cammino di assumono una dimensione molto
ma molto piccole questo è una delle cose
più importanti che mi ha dato
il cammino di santiago il cammino di
santiago come il viaggio è una sorta di
metafora della vita si segue una freccia
gialla una conchiglia anch'essa gialla
che porta verso la cattedrale di
santiago bene questi segnali possono
essere i nostri ideali
i nostri valori e la cattedrale i nostri
traguardi personali ma allora è la
cattedrale il premio di un viaggio del
genere
no io credo che il premio stia proprio
nel cammino sia nei passi che abbiamo
fatto da soli ma che abbiamo anche
condiviso nelle persone in tutto quello
che abbiamo fatto nella gioia nel dolore
e nella sofferenza per arrivare qui in
questa esatta latitudine longitudine del
mondo in questo momento
il premio è assolutamente nel viaggio è
nel cammino io col mio silenzio quello
che mi porto dentro è torno con una
maggiore propensione all'ascolto
accondiscendenza pazienza
[Musica]
sì